the real goat and I've been throwing the
word gold around a lot but Pharrell is
number one everyone's got to pay homage
to Pharrell when it comes to this
jewelry game you got the multi-colored
Gucci links with the famous nerd piece
probably the most iconic piece of all
time it just went into auction right now
I actually believe Drake bought the
piece yo yo what's up GQ I'm always the
Jeweler I'm a jeweler in New York City
who's been doing this for the past
decade and today we're gonna be looking
at chains and pendants worn by the
biggest rappers in the game today
[Music]
what we got here is uh Drake wearing uh
one of the craziest pieces I've ever
seen we'll probably be in a museum one
day this piece was called I believe a
previous engagements it was done by Alex
Moss I think it's around like 14 months
to make this so right here we got 42
different diamonds every single one is
supposed to represent each one of
Drake's lovers in this lifetime of
course being the certified lover boy
that he is supposed to be an engagement
ring every single stone that add up to a
total of 351 carats if you do the math
on that that's an average of eight
carats to nine carrot per Stone to even
own one of those in a lifetime is
shocking and Drake has 42 on his neck
over here you have Emerald Cuts in there
you have Asher Cuts you have pear shapes
you have rounds literally every single
special cut which is
costs over 10 million easily Van Cleef
and arpel this is actually one of the
biggest Trends that's going on right now
in the last year actually where a couple
myself as you can see very classic piece
he's wearing the one with the white
mother of pearl in the 18 karat white
gold this is something that's just uh if
you know you know type of piece you know
he said I'm gonna wear this with my iced
out sky dweller I believe that's a
factory Sky dwell on his wrist it's over
a million dollar piece over there also
mother of pearl is a natural stone from
the ocean of course in order to create
this you actually have to cut the stone
in The Motif shape and then set it
inside actually not supposed to wear it
in water or anything because it could
get dehydrated that at Van Cleef will
probably be around like 18 000 retail
[Music]
ASAP Rocky is a big art collector and he
said you know I have a couple of these
special bear bricks in my home I
actually want to bring one to life and
put it on my neck so whichever jewelry
he had make that again takes
crazy amount of skill because as you can
see all the pieces are done separate so
they're able to move this is a fully
functional jewelry piece you need to
have a very skilled Jeweler who also
understands mechanics of course every
single piece has to be done separate and
you need to make sure that everything is
able to move correctly without the piece
breaking on you again it's very
different when you're handling gold and
diamonds as opposed to just a regular
base metal because gold is a lot softer
so when you're dealing with gold you
want to make sure that this can handle
the wear and tear as opposed to a
regular base metal the OG kufi Jesus
over there shout out Biggie Smalls who
popularized it oh gee Jesus Piece man
this is a piece that was uh huge from
the 90s and now we're seeing rappers
like ASAP Rocky bringing them back you
know Trends always come back whatever
was hot in the 90s you had the big baggy
clothes then it went to the tight and
now we're back in baggy just like we're
seeing right now with the Kofi Jesus
this is a direct inspiration from
Pharrell's chain but Tyler said let's go
a little different I want to have that
uh that gumball machine feel on my neck
and when it comes to a piece like this
it takes a lot more work because when it
comes to those balls those balls are
iced out 360. so with the diamonds over
here of course you have the natural
white diamonds and I would assume you
use natural yellow diamonds because they
don't get so crazy expensive when it
comes to the Natural yellow but with the
blues and pinks I would have to assume
that they were doing a radiation which
means that you color intensify the stone
so they are natural diamonds but they do
go through a certain process to bring
out a different type of color in the
stone because if those were natural
pinks and blues we'd be hearing it on
the news this piece could have been
worth 10 million dollars crazy 3D 3D
work on the big money man holding the
briefcases over there it's crazy work on
that just to make all that stuff done
again the briefcases have to have been
done separate and to continue to hold
all that detail while still drilling
into the piece and setting the stones I
believe this is Alex Smalls who made
this piece
great job
[Music]
a lot of work over here probably woke up
that morning and said all right I'm
throwing on everything I got because uh
I really want to show what I uh what I
put my money into so as you can see we
have three different huge custom pieces
on his neck accommodated by three
different Cubans all different lengths
to hold the pieces in different areas of
his neck the top Cuban the shortest one
actually got bigger pointers in there
those are like three to four pointers on
his neck and that gives you a different
effect as opposed to like the tighter
smaller one pointer type Cuban so he
said I want to have that contrast
between all these different Cubans
Superstar stuff 100 points will equal
one carat so when people say oh I got a
10 pointer chain on that means I have
one tenth of a carrot per Stone on my
neck chain like this is 60 pointers each
this will run you around the hundred
thousand dollars for a chain like this
so every single Stone here is 60th out
of 100 so it would be a little bit
bigger of half a carrot so 60 of a full
carrot so Nord awake and the smaller
Cubans those are around one pointers
each and then on the top Cuban that he's
wearing holding his Wick piece those
look to me like three to four pointers
of course the bigger a diamond becomes
the more value it is so everyone says oh
if I bring you 100 stones at one
pointers each can you make me one single
Stone a carrot out of it unfortunately
no because a one carat stone will cost
you around six thousand dollars and one
carrot in small stones will run you
around like five hundred dollars
[Music]
Hey space baby the queen of New York now
she really made a name for herself I'm
feeling spicy when I when I uh when I
see a piece like that on her neck
extremely three-dimensional that piece
is probably holding I'd say 6 000 stones
in there I believe Benny the Jeweler
made this one so a piece I guess first
of all
to even set those diamonds in the hair
as you can see all those different nooks
and crannies over there very hard to set
but they obviously got it done for her
and then after they put that hot pink
lipstick on the lips which was done
after the diamond setting of course
because if you're gonna put enamel on a
piece before Diamond setting then the
diamond set it could mess up the enamel
by uh touching it with his tools so of
course to give the contrast to the piece
also after the diamond setting they did
a nice little outline of black enamel
have the eyes to really give it its uh
definition and the three-dimensional
look
[Music]
one of the jewelry goats over here Meek
Mill man since that role he first
touched his wrist he really went crazy
he said uh I'm gonna go down as one of
the biggest jewelry collectors of all
time in the hip-hop game and as we can
see over here he just threw on a whole
bunch of different pieces on his neck
he's got the DC and emerald Cuts I can't
even imagine how many times he made this
DC piece also he did it with one
characters with shine Jewelers he did so
many different micro pave ones that he
gifted to his team and over here he got
done by my brother uh pristine over
there he got the custom DC done in
Emerald cuts and then he has the DC
dream catcher piece right next to it
which also amazing piece a lot of
details a lot of definition all those
balls separately done attached assembled
together piece like that does take a lot
of effort a lot of time very colorful
very fun outlandish and uh stands out
almost anywhere he hiding in between all
those chains as you can see he's got
those yellow diamonds which looks to me
around like a 80 pointers to a carrot
each and the chain like that every
single Stone could run you around 6
thousand dollars so you do the math he's
got a 100 stones in there that's uh
seven hundred thousand dollars drawing
him back in his bank account
apology has been going crazy in the
jewelry game you know now I've been
seeing this trend where whatever he's
creating everyone's now following in the
beginning everyone Meek Mill was like
that trendsetter first he did the
picture pendants and every one of the
picture pendant then he did the DC
plates and then everyone wanted to play
with their own logo now I feel like Polo
G took that Throne where he's creating
the pieces and everyone's now following
his footsteps what you got over here you
got Polo G wearing this uh insane custom
piece that I only think is going to last
probably a year or two for him because
iPhone changes their design every single
year and what you got over here you got
this uh big vicious dog holding his
iPhone it's custom done of course every
single B has to be done separately you
have to create different waxes for every
single bee cast them clean them up set
the diamonds in there and then you have
to enamel that Outer Rim which he did
the the red color to represent the
Boston Red Sox color and then you have
to attach every single link together so
a piece like this takes a lot of time a
lot of creativity and you cannot make
any mistakes when you create a piece
like this everything has to be done to
the exact T to make sure that no issues
while he wears this piece back in the
day it was at the other Cuban Link a
tennis chain or something like that and
now you're able to get very creative if
you have your own logo you can create
your own logo chain as you can see over
here Polo G wearing the B chain there's
so many different links that have been
created even for example this was a
chain that I made over here that I did
with the special Fox and on this link we
did the fox to link with some Fox pause
so you're able to think of any design
and if your Jeweler is skilled enough
and has the correct people on his team
he's able to make any of your dreams
come true
oh
so we got here a little baby a huge
innovator and a huge uh huge influencer
in his jewelry game got unimaginable
amount of pieces an unimaginable amount
of chains and as you can see over here
he's wearing his special wamp piece a
different type of nameplate where he
said you know I did so many 4pf pieces
that were straight he said let's change
it up I want to do a Wham piece let's
have the letter Rings done different and
I really wanted to stand out so maybe
he's creating a new trend right now for
the name plates maybe people are going
to be following this now of course he's
got a bunch of different tennis chains
with huge rocks in there he's got an
Infinity link on his neck with also one
row Solitaire big diamonds solitaire
means single Stone you know instead of
doing a cluster and having a bunch of
smaller stones in the infinity link you
see it's just one row of big diamonds we
would call that Solitaire when he says
make my jewelry he says I got no budget
just go crazy for me I need to stand out
I'm a little baby I'm the man in this
jewelry game so let it be known let me
show the people how how big I am in this
oh
that cardi B over here rocking this
insane Playboy piece letting everyone
know that she's the uh the Real Player
over here she's the big dog just imagine
even those four small bunnies you got
over there could be someone's regular
pendants but she said I want to make the
big Playboy piece and then make four
smaller ones hanging off my chain
because I'm cardi B and I need to uh to
show out my chain is not like anyone
else's so she really went crazy with the
flare I see a big nice Ruby as the eye
to give it that contrast and really
bring the piece to life in its fullest
form four hundred thousand on this piece
if that is a natural Ruby even a one-two
character in that quality can run
a lot of money I've seen some rubies go
for 10 20 000 per carat so we do the
math on that one
escg one on stage he said let me go
crazy I'm throwing everything and it
really is giving that crazy effect and
you got glorilla in the back shining
with her also pearly white teeth
sticking out matching the diamonds you
know that chain I'm looking at it is
like he's paying homage to it Nas's QB
piece Nazar is a famous Queensbridge
piece that he did and that was the same
exact structured Bell that Naz did back
in the 90s he said you know let me uh
let me go for that same style let me pay
how much to the to the old school let me
do the new school style so as you can
see he did all this micro pave setting
which is assuming he's got 70 80 carrots
and diamonds just in that piece alone
big showstopper they have a bunch of
different levels in that piece as you
can see the letters are sticking out and
then he has also that bezel around which
just has that big like pillowy effect
giving it all its contrast for the
diamonds to hit its best way we've seen
the game change tremendously just in the
last decade if you saw the earlier
pieces done with Jacob the Jeweler for
Pharrell and so if you don't see as much
as I mentioned even though those pieces
are so legendary you see the difference
just in the last 10 years in this game
so somebody wants to design their first
piece first of all make sure you have
the correct budget for the piece you
want to bring to life you know I always
have people that they come they got a 5k
budget but they want a 50k piece you
know I always say it's also a marathon
don't rush yourself into your first
piece if you want save up find the
Jeweler that you like his work and go
make sure that he brings what you want
to life yo thank you guys for watching
I'll move this to Jeweler love with GQ
peace
thank you